you have just witnessed the grace the
beauty and the artistry that is pure 0
to Z fact that we are honoring this
extraordinary five-time Oscar nominee
tonight is an appropriate climax to an
exciting year for costume designers this
year for the first time in Academy
history the Board of Governors has voted
to form the costume design branch
Bureau Josie is a giant in the world of
film design it is not merely the
Magnificent clothing be it period or
contemporary but a master's I in color
and fabrication and a writer's eloquence
in visual storytelling he has created
images that are sealed in the minds of
filmmakers everywhere I remember the
first time I saw a film designed by
Bureau to see it's like being a kid in a
candy store I was mesmerised I was
thrilled I watched that screen and
thought this is what I must do this is
why I want to become with us tonight are
some of the best of the best in our
field we all agree PR Tosi is the
greatest of the great and now to accept
on his behalf I am thrilled and honored
to introduce one of his collaborators
simply put a legend the internationally
renowned claudia cardinale